and today we are going to talk to Neil
desmani who is kind of not your
um typical faculty member you might have
heard from before he also has let so
many uh industry jobs and he has so much
experience in the field
like he he worked in research
development teaching and executive roles
uh at companies like symantech and live
Vlog Twitter
Etc and right now he's working actually
as Chief cyber SEC Chief information
security officer at quantumscape so he
really brings the industry perspective
in and we are so glad that he took the
time to join us for his webinar I think
without further Ado uh I think we can
kick it out Neil
um thank you so much once again for
joining us great thank you Petra for
having me I always love doing webinars
and courses for Stanford so in today's
webinar we're going to talk about
breaking and entering into the cyber
security field I'm going to talk a
little bit about just the uh cyber
security landscape uh you know how many
jobs are out there what kind of jobs are
there uh depending upon what you're
doing today what might be some potential
paths uh going forward and look forward
to covering all that and then hopefully
answer some questions so let's go ahead
and get started so first of all what has
been going on in the cyber security
field there have been over the past 17
years there have been
over 20 000 breaches that have taken
place data breaches and other kinds of
breaches uh there's been almost two
billion consumer records that have been
impacted there has been a whole bunch of
different root causes for these breaches
on this slide on the top right it shows
some of those root causes we can see
that most of them are due to hacking of
various kinds there's a large percentage
that's also unknown and uncategorized
there's uh you know a small number of
Insider attacks there's
you know if you look at some of the
other bars together with regards to
Portable devices or physical security in
the red and green if you combine those
there's been a lot of breaches due to
lost or stolen media there's been some
organizations that have just gotten
breached over and over again and so if
you kind of look at field overall we've
got to ask ourselves what's what's
what's been going on here and about two
years ago myself and Moody Alberti we
published a book entitled big breaches
which dives into these root causes if we
go to the next slide here one of the
things that I want to note is that the
first
state law around
data breaches and the requirement of
reporting data breaches to the
government to say state attorney
generals that law was first passed to
2003 in California
and since then there has been a lot of
data that's been aggregated around
breaches that have taken place and just
that reporting is a great first step to
first of all understand what's going on
if people are getting attacked and we
don't share the information about who
got attacked how they got attacked how
can we do better next time then it's
hard for the field to to advance now
looking 10 years later after 2003 what
happened in the landscape is that a
whole bunch of Mega breaches started
starting with Target followed by
JPMorgan Chase followed by the US
government's office of personnel
management and then year after year
after year there's pretty much some big
breach of one kind or another the
largest breach in the history of the
internet as measured by the number of
accounts that were compromised happened
due to Yahoo back in 2016 the largest
cloud security breach as we know there's
a lot of services that are moving from
on-premise data centers to clouds run by
Amazon and Microsoft and Google and the
largest cloud security data breach was
due to Capital One back in 2019 uh the
largest financial identity breach
occurred in 2017 uh at Equifax
approximately half of the countries
personally The Identical I felt the
person identifiable information
associated with financial credit
applications was was stolen from Equifax
so there's been more and more impact due
to these breaches so uh looking even
just two years ago we had seen the
colonial oil pipeline get breached
attackers had
shut down the oil pipeline for about a
week they demanded a ransomware payment
in excess of four million dollars which
uh the CEO at Colonial pipeline paid
after a week and
after that particular incident
ransomware got declared as a national
security threat and Biden issued an
executive order around
protecting the assets of federal
agencies and directing them to uh put
more defenses in for their supply chain
so there's a deep deep need to have more
people enter this field one of the
questions that might come to your mind
is wow this all sounds pretty darn bad
how did we get to this point and if we
go back to the 1970s when the internet
was first designed the TCP and IP
standard some were first designed
security was a bit of an afterthought in
the initial design of those protocols
that now run the internet but and there
were many proposals as to how to network
the world together at that time but
tcpip won out because of the fact that
it was relatively simple and it was it
had a whole bunch of interoperability
benefits whereas a bunch of other
protocols were more complicated were not
as interoperable maybe had more security
thrown there up front but got in the way
of adoption and so TCP had TCP and IP
had just an amazing amount of Success
With regards to getting adopted like
wildfire
um you know by by you know first here in
the US with the arpanet and then as the
internet got commercialized in the 1990s
uh all around the world
um if we think about what are the root
causes of data breaches that have taken
place there's
probably only about a handful of them
which is kind of interesting given that
there has been so many security
compliance standards that have been
developed over time whether it's PCI
HIPAA
um ISO 27000 whatever it happens to be
each of these compliance standards have
two or three hundred different check
boxes and companies go around checking
them the irony of it all is that most
organizations that get breached have
been compliant with one or more security
standards at the time of reach so we've
got to ask ourselves what's going on one
of the things that um uh that that we've
done is identified you know looking at
all these breaches what have been the
root causes of these breaches and
there's typically you know just five or
six of them things like phishing an
account takeover malicious software
software vulnerabilities account
takeover unencrypted data and the reason
that these root causes exist is because
you know going back to the initial
design of for instance the email
security the email protocols on the
internet there was no security built in
right when the arpanet was just a set of
military institutions and
um you know educational institutions
communicating with each other pretty
much just in the US every institution
trusted every institution anybody could
send an email to anybody else claiming
to be whoever they wanted to be
um and over time as the internet got
commercialized there have been more
email security protocols that have been
put in place but we we still fishing is
still one of the most common root causes
of breach
um you know there's there's a lot of
other kind of history and background as
to why there's still so many
vulnerabilities and browsers and plug
into the browsers and web applications
um you know uh
that I won't get into here but but I
guess I just wanted to comment that
there's kind of a long history of you
know why we are at the place that we're
at and my hope and expectation is that
over the coming decades more and more
countermeasures and defenses will be put
in place from a technical perspective
but also we'll all get more educated
just as was the case with cars and
driving it wasn't until the you know you
know while uh automobile started coming
out in the 1920s it really wasn't until
the 1960s and 70s that for instance
Volvo came out with the first lap and
shoulder seat belt and
um you know people it then became a law
that you have to wear a seatbelt right
so over time I look forward to seeing
the cyber security industry and the
industry overall
you know benefit more and more from from
the learnings from from breaches
with regards to where we are in terms of
employment in terms of cyber security
employment in the United States there
are currently about 1.1 million people
employed in the cyber security field in
the U.S which is which is good but there
are over 750
000 jobs that are currently open there's
a website called cyberseek.org that
tracks open cyber security jobs and how
many people are employed and you can go
to their website to see some of those
stats there's a whole variety of jobs
that need to be filled in the cyber
security field probably one of the most
common jobs that need to be filled the
the entry level position in the field is
that of cyber security analyst last I
checked the statistics on the U.S Labor
Bureau there were over 130 000 cyber
security analyst jobs available and
we'll talk about what cyber security
analysts do but there's also a whole
bunch of other roles that are required
and needed cyber security Engineers
managers systems Engineers software
developers penetration testers
Etc so there's a whole bunch of myths
that exist so I had done some searching
as to uh you know around articles as to
why there aren't more people in the
field and it turns out that there's a
bunch of myths as to why people don't
enter the cyber security field one of
those myths is that you have to be super
technical you have to be a computer
genius that is just simply not the case
you don't have to be super technical you
don't have to be a genius to enter the
cyber security field we need all kinds
of all kinds of people
to help not just you know build defenses
but deploy defenses we need project
managers you know one of the things
about cyber security is that in most
companies you might have a cyber
security team but that cyber security
team is typically a small percentage of
the number of employees that are hired
into the into the software organization
or into the IT organization
um cyber security is also not just an
I.T problem so in order to
roll out a whole bunch of changes across
a company you need project managers you
need program managers
um you know one way to look at the
security team is there might be a small
number of security Jedis but you know we
need the help of a clone army to roll
out some of the defenses and to execute
on those defenses in order to defend a
company people used to think that cyber
security is a narrow field Cyrus
security is definitely not a narrow
field anymore even if it might have been
a narrow field 20 or 30 years ago
um
you know if you look at most Chief
information security officers uh the
types of people uh you know that head up
security for an organization they also
don't know everything about the field
they you know one of the things I'll
talk about is that they may need to have
certain areas of expertise but they they
don't know everything and so it's a very
it's a very broad field now so I'm not
going to go through each of these myths
but except to just say that they're
they're false and I'll pick maybe maybe
one additional one around the hours and
the pay for cyber security are not good
uh let's talk about that actually right
now so looking at this data from the US
Bureau of Labor Statistics from just
about one year ago the
average wage
for the entry level position of an
information security analyst in the
field is a six-figure salary of a
hundred and twelve thousand dollars I
think the laws of supply and demand
apply to cyber security just as they
apply to everything else as per one of
the things that we talked about on a
previous slide there is a negative
employment rate of 75 percent we need so
many more people to enter this field
there's a relatively short supply of
cyber Security Professionals and as a
result you know given the demand their
their their salaries are going to be are
going to be higher than average now one
of the things that I'll also mention is
that whatever you decide to do in life
um
you should uh you know do it primarily
for for the enjoyment
um we'll talk about some of the
characteristics
um definitely need to Smart you know
work smart will work hard but one of the
things to keep in mind is that you know
if you're good at what you do you'll
probably earn more money doing it than
if you're if you're not as good so that
applies to cyber security as well we can
see that the the lowest 10 percent has
an annual wage of sixty six thousand
dollars the um highest uh you know 90
percentile for the same role for the
same role is 174 000 a year whereas the
media is 112 000. so those are just some
statistics uh around
um around around that and so
you know if there was a previous myth
that the hours and the pay for cyber
security are not good that that is not
true the pay uh can be very good with
regards to hours I think that
people in the field are also realizing
that it's important that you have
work-life balance if you want to avoid
having your best people burn out for
instance and so a lot of times companies
will hire third-party uh Security
operation centers or they'll hire folks
to work in shifts uh you know as needed
kind of around the globe follow the sun
eight hours in different geographies uh
to even just handle the most significant
most high pressure incident response
jobs but many of the jobs in cyber
security uh can have a very good balance
and it's really dependent upon the
management of the organization and what
kind of culture they look at creating
so what is driving all of these jobs why
are there so many uh people that are
that are needed and
there's I found a great article by uh
Amit Doshi on LinkedIn which I've
provided a link to in the bottom right
here but some of the the key drivers of
the growth are as we've talked about the
increasing number of data breaches
um ransomware has particularly grown
rents more attacks ransomware as a type
of malicious software that when it
infects a computer what it does is it
will encrypt all of the data on that
machine making it inaccessible to the to
the owner of the machine and only making
it accessible to the attacker and they
basically demand a ransom uh sometimes
in the millions of dollars
in order to give the legitimate user an
encryption key I'm sorry right a
decryption key so that they can you know
use their own data and ransomware has
grown from 2017 looking at incidents
like wannacry where over a hundred
thousand organizations including
hospitals were in you know infected and
you know couldn't take care of some of
their patients some people died in those
hospitals because of that attack back in
um to uh the colonial oil pipeline
grants for incident which I mentioned in
2021 even still today in 2023 while
things have gotten a little bit better
ransomware is still a significant issue
also there's many many businesses that
are in the midst of their digital
Transformations so pretty much once your
business goes all digital or larger
percent digital than it was before then
the digital attack surface of the
company also grows there's also been a
lot more compliance regulations to
follow if we look at for instance in
Europe the uh epr the general data
protection regulation Act and the
version of it in California CCPA are
examples of regulations you know beyond
the breach notification laws that first
started here in California back in 2003.
uh the final thing that I'll mention is
that as we've all probably been
witnessing over the past several months
there has been a revel and not just past
several months but past several years
there's been an absolute Revolution
taking place in the field of artificial
intelligence uh leading to both all
kinds of positive benefits as well as
all kinds of challenges you know all
kinds of positive benefits include
things like being able to automate away
jobs so for instance even the 750 000
open jobs that are available in the
cyber security field I don't think
there's going to be any way to fill
those jobs realistically we're going to
have to automate and we're going to have
to use AI to help us automate away some
of the most entry-level jobs I'll also
chat a little bit more about that
um but you know there's also a whole
bunch of downsides attackers are using
artificial intelligence to generate
better phishing emails than they were
ever previously able to so if previously
one was able to detect a phishing email
because there's bad grammar or bad
spelling like that's all gone right
attackers can now use AI uh in services
like chat jpt to generate their their
attacks for them so there's a lot of
reasons for this for this growth
I thought it might be useful to talk
about what may be the typical structure
of a security team in a medium-sized
company typically headed up by
um you know some head of security
whether it is a chief information
security officer or whether it's say
somebody in a director or VP level
position uh leading the organization uh
one way to organize a security team is
to say have three different subgroups
one group for GRC typically called
governance risk and compliance
um you know followed by a group that
focuses on security engineering followed
by a group that focuses on security
operations the GRC group will be
responsible if the company has to comply
with certain security standards like ISO
27000 or PCI to protect credit cards or
hit by to protect Healthcare information
whatever it happens to be the compliance
Department can help do that there have
also been a lot of breaches that have
happened due to third parties getting
attacked first so if we look at the
breaches that JPMorgan Chase or Target
back in 2014 and 2013 respectively the
way that they got broken into given that
they were very big corporations spending
decent amounts on security but one could
always spend more
attackers got broken by targeting some
of their suppliers and their vendors in
the Target reach it was their heating
and air conditioning provider that first
got broken into in the case of JPMorgan
Chase it was a company that was running
their website for charitable marathon
races that got broken into first so the
government governance risk and
compliance group also typically handles
third-party risk and helping vet all the
suppliers and third parties that company
works with to make sure that they have
just as good security or better security
you know ideally before they come on
board as a supplier but but sometimes
afterwards as well
then there may be a group that has to
focus on security engineering that has
to focus on building and deploying the
internal systems that help protect the
corporation as well as uh helping
protect the products or the software
applications if the company builds
software applications and that's
typically what goes on a security
engineering team security operations
teams typically deal with managing
access to systems
um and the identities uh both the
legitimate identities of the employees
as well as the contractors to figure out
who should be allowed to access what and
why and what you know what roles should
be given access to things companies all
can also bring in a whole bunch of
threat intelligence so that when they
get attacked they can tell who is
attacking them who are their adversaries
and how should they drive their security
Investments forward based on who's
specifically targeting them many
security operations group also have a
security operations center either run
internally or run by a third party and
that group helps with things like
incident fonts which um you know
incident response teams can sometimes be
uh you know dedicated sets of employees
that focus on just responding incidents
or sometimes they're virtual teams you
can imagine that there's trade-offs so
for instance if you have a virtual
incident response team and you pull
other security people in or you pull
people in from other departments when
you responding to an incident it may
take away from some of the proactive
work that those
uh parts of the company need to do to
defend better and so you don't want to
get into this state where you're just
you know doing too much instant response
and not doing enough proactive work so
anyhow hopefully this gives a sense for
what the structure of an example
security team is and a medium sized
company what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to talk a little bit about
different roles within this team so that
you can get a sense of what cyber
security jobs are like and before we do
that one of the things that I wanted to
do with regards to how to get a cyber
security job you may be in a particular
job today and one question that you
might have is what kinds of roles might
be most natural for me to go into if I
want to get into cyber security so in
the in this slide and the next one what
I do is I have a set of a table where on
the left side it lists a set of roles
say that you one might currently have so
you might currently be a it system
administrator you might currently be a
network engineer it might currently be a
software developer you might currently
be a QA faster and based on what your
current role is there might be certain
cyber security roles that are just more
natural for you to be able to go into
given the experience that you've built
to date so what I've done on this slide
and by the way this this this this table
comes from uh the big breaches cyber
security lessons for everyone book in
the very last chapter we talk about how
you can get in the field of cyber
security
um so here's a bunch of different roles
that you can you can go into if you're
an I.T system administrator you've
you've learned uh what you need to do to
build systems deploy systems you may
also be used to having god-like powers
on your network for instance and so with
that set of experience
going into roles like cyber security
analysts information security analyst
sock analyst penetration tester etc
those might be good roles to try to move
to adjacently
um you know if you're a quality
assurance tester
and you're somebody who's naturally
curious to find bugs in software systems
then going into a role of a penetration
tester or a vulnerability analyst maybe
a good role if you want to break into
the field of cyber security
because what penetration testers do is
they they they're pretty much trying to
find certain kinds of bugs they're
trying to find certain kinds of bugs
that could allow an attacker to break in
to to a company or into a software
system
if you've previously been a software
architect then becoming a security
architect might be a good uh way to go
and if you've been an I.T engineer
moving into a role of a corporate
security engineer might be might be a
good way to go
um there's also some cyber security
roles that are that are not as technical
that are maybe pseudo-technical where
you have to bridge both the technical
and the non-technical aspects of what
need to get done and so if say in the
past you've been a auditor for a uh say
Financial audits uh then there might be
the opportunity to go into a cyber
security auditor position all the big
four companies accounting companies that
do
Financial audits also do cyber security
Audits and
learning if you have past experience
about what it's like to carry out an
audit the same many of the same
principles May apply in order to do an
audit on the financial side for instance
you're going to ask for financial
statements you're going to ask for
evidence that the books are being
managed properly and if you're a cyber
security auditor you're going to do the
same for the field of cyber security
you're going to see what are the
different records that are being kept
around you know what are all the assets
that a company has how have they been
secured what what defenses are in place
what evidence can be provided around
that that's what cyber security Auditors
do I had mentioned earlier that in order
to make changes at the organization in
order to achieve cyber security uh you
typically need to get entire departments
to make changes uh and so project
managers and product managers can help
especially security project managers can
help roll such things out if you're part
of a software company and you're
building a secure a software product
then if the security of that product is
important to the company they may have
one or more security product managers
um you know back earlier in my own
career at Google I had started at Google
in 2005 as an engineer after after
um you know earning my education
Stanford and then I after helping make a
bunch of engineering contributions I was
asked if I wanted to serve as a product
manager a security product manager to
help multiple groups
um with achieving security goals in in
the products and the internal offerings
so that's a particular path that I have
to take
you know one other uh you know
pseudo-technical cyber security role is
that of a chief information security
officer or a chief security officer
abbreviated a csor or CSO and uh you
know that's a that's a role that I
currently serve in uh today
um uh today at quantumscape I've also
been a CSO at uh semantic and LifeLock
and those are definitely roles where
um I'll talk about it in more detail but
you have to spend a lot of time working
with the executive leaders at the
company to help achieve security and
make security a characteristic of the
organization just like you know when a
company builds a product uh they don't
build a product and then try to make it
a quality product that's typically a
hard path to follow rather
characteristics like quality have to be
built in from the beginning and the same
holds true of security so see so one of
the cso's goals should be to help embed
the characteristic of quality into the
company's development and operations as
things are getting built and rolled out
so any case that's a little bit about
some pseudo-technical cyber security
roles
so what I'm going to do now is go
through three of these roles and just
talk a little bit about what the career
path can look like so let me start
actually with the career path for
security
analysts uh sometimes also called
security operations center analysts the
typical profile of a person that is a
good fit to become a security analyst uh
the typical entry-level role is that
they should have some Good Foundations
in Information Technology if there's
some foundation in security that's great
but that's not a required must the
foundations in it are the are the most
the other characteristics that are
really good to have is Natural Curiosity
you want to dig deeper you want to
understand why things are the way they
are you want to understand how can you
how can you make things better and you
think about all the different potential
things that can go wrong in a very uh
you know risk driven way what's the
what's the highest risk thing could go
wrong what's the next highest risk of
thing can go wrong and what kind of
countermeasures can you put in place in
order to to prevent against that so for
people that come from the financial
field they're usually used to thinking
about managing money in a way that you
want to be prepared for the worst but
you want to expect and or hope for the
best and so if you have that kind of
characteristic if you enjoy solving
puzzles if you enjoy detective shows
those are great characteristics too
uh go into the cyber security field with
as a cyber security analyst what cyber
security analysts do is if you think
about things from the attacker
standpoint and you look at this flow
chart that I have here this flowchart
shows what is the typical life cycle
that an attacker goes through in order
to break into an organization and
complete their mission whatever that
happens to be whether it be stealing
intellectual property taking a service
offline stealing data
etc etc etc you know the attackers
typically start with doing some initial
reconnaissance
um then they make an initial compromise
the attacker's goals typically involve
compromising machines and or
compromising accounts once they have
compromised one or more machines or
accounts that's typically called their
foothold uh they they establish their
foothold and then by uh going about a
series of activities they grow their
foothold they compromise more machines
they compromise more accounts they get
more and more privileges inside of an
organization uh while they might have
started doing external reconnaissance
once they have uh done some of that
external reconnaissance and have a
foothold then they start doing internal
reconnaissance within their organization
to understand what else can they take
over how can they move laterally how do
they continue to maintain their foothold
and grow it until they can complete
their mission and what security analysts
do is that when certain attempted
attacks come in like phishing attacks or
malware attacks security analysts are
typically the people that are on the
front line identifying that that initial
compromise has occurred word and then
taking steps to go ahead and kick them
out so let's say that say somebody's
somebody received a phishing email they
got lured to a website which lured them
to provide their username and password
well the second that they perhaps
realized that they might have been duped
or there's some internal systems that
identify that that event has happened
the security analyst will go in
um start working with that user to
change their credentials as fast as
possible right just because an initial
compromise has occurred it doesn't mean
that it's game over right so if you can
change the credentials and then the
attacker can no longer use the
compromise credentials to log into
accounts and view activities within
systems then you can cut those attackers
off similarly with malware if a machine
gets infected that happens all the time
but the important thing is to to
basically once a machine's been infected
identify it contain it cut that machine
off and and say re-image that machine
with a new operating system and a new
set of applications and security
analysts are typically the people that
are on the front line for helping do
that kind of work as well as automating
that kind of work as as we're we're in a
world here where artificial intelligence
and a whole bunch of things are used to
automate
um those are the things to automate one
of the things I've done here in this
slide is talked about what are the root
causes of breaches and what are the
typical kinds of activities that
security analysts do I already talked
about the example of how you can reset
credentials once a phishing attack has
happened to prevent the attacker from
doing anything bad I talked about
malware a little bit I don't have time
to talk about all these uh items but uh
these are the kinds of things that
security analysts do to help mitigate
the root causes of breach
um you know I would encourage folks that
want to become security analysts to
develop familiarity with how attacks are
carried out
um if you're say a quality assurance
tester and you want to become a security
analyst I'd encourage you to try out a
tool called Metasploit which is a
toolkit that can help you actually Mount
attacks and then once you understand how
to mount tax please do this safely
please do this only on test systems
don't do this on production systems once
you understand how attacks are carried
out you can also then understand very
well how you can cut off a tax you know
that are in progress or attempted
attacks I would also encourage you to
learn about scripting programming and
automation as there are so many security
analysts roles and we just won't be able
to fill them in the field the important
thing to do is to figure out how can you
automate out the most basic activities
so if for instance you want to become a
security analyst and there's different
levels of security analysts you know
starting with level one going up to
level two going up to level three Etc
different organizations may have
different levels
um but you know uh you I mean you don't
want to become a level one security
analyst whose job then just gets
outsourced later on so to prevent that
what you do is you become a security
analyst and you also learn about
programming and scripting and Automation
and then you can help automate all the
tasks that the security analysts can do
if you look at the typical definitions
of a level two or a level three security
analysts they're typically the folks who
automate away the level one activities
so we're we're still a far ways from
having even the level one jobs automated
out of the world but if we want to make
as much progress in the field as we can
I would recommend learning about
programming and scripting and automation
uh you know
to become a security analyst that gets
up to that level two level three tier
and then can take on other roles as well
another career path to enter the field
of cyber security is that of a security
architect uh my my biggest piece of
advice is to make sure you become a good
software architect first become a good
software developer become a good
software engineer become a good
programmer and then become a software
architect and then become a security
architect and the reason I suggest that
order is because once you pursue things
in that order and you understand what it
takes to develop good software then and
you establish credibility as a software
architect then what you can do is help
give advice to other software Architects
and other software engineers and because
you have that credibility and you know
their pains and you know that they're
trying to you know launch a new feature
every week and they're they're you know
working on the stories and the testing
and the whole devops part of it because
you understand their world you'll be
able to give them better advice that
they'll that they'll receive I'd also
encourage you to learn about different
types of software security attacks
whether they be buffer overflows code
injections SQL injections cross-site
scripting attacks cross-site request
forgery attacks we covered a lot of
these types of tax in our web
applications uh course here here at
Stanford
um and then to kind of graduate and kind
of like get that get that Jedi uh you
know credibility I would encourage you
to find some zero day vulnerabilities in
existing software projects perhaps open
source projects a zero day vulnerability
is simply a a software vulnerability a
bug that simply hasn't been discovered
yet where you're the first to find it
and if you get credited for those cves
then uh uh cve stands for common
vulnerability enumeration it's a
designation it's an identifier that's
given to a vulnerability once you find
it and you report it to the National
vulnerability database so if you if you
can get some credit for finding some you
know zero day vulnerabilities you're the
first one to find them that positions
you very well to be a to be a respected
soft security architect
um let's see I don't have much time to
talk about uh other things on that on
that front
um uh you can of course read the last
chapter of the big reaches book
um but let me also cover the CSO career
path so if you want to become a chief
information security officer my advice
would be to develop you know two to four
domain spikes in certain areas of
information security uh I don't think
there is any Chief security officer out
there that's an expert at everything
cyber security the field is so broad
these days that I think it makes sense
to develop uh spikes uh in certain
domains so for instance you know before
I became a chief information security
officer I had become an expert in web
application security I had become an
expert in anti-malware defenses I had
also become an expert in certain Niche
areas like click fraud and malicious
advertising
um and it's good to have those domain
spikes so that you make sure you
understand the principles the principal
tenets of the field and you have somehow
operational experience with them I think
every CSO should hire uh relevant uh you
know directors or VPS or principals that
help complement out for other areas
where they don't have the the depth of
experience and listen to them
um I would also encourage you if you
want to become a CSO to get experience
doing different Hands-On jobs within
within a security team so that you
understand the different parts of what
the security organization does if you
can get some experience with engineering
security engineering some experience
with security operations some experience
with compliance those are great
experiences that will help you do the
job better and understand the pains that
your directs are going through
um I would also encourage you to you
know finish becoming a CSO develop a lot
of soft skills because it's really the
soft skills and the relationships that
you make with other people at the
company uh whether it be the CEO or
other folks that will help you get the
job done and then I think it's also very
important to become a good explainer and
a story teller Steve Jobs who was the
previous CEO at Apple the first CEO the
co-founding CEO at Apple uh he he said
that the most powerful person in the
world is a Storyteller I agree with that
I think it's important to be able to
explain to especially non-technical and
pseudo-technical people all the complex
technical stuff but with all the complex
without all the complex technical stuff
we're going to explain things using
analogies whenever whenever you can so
long as the analogies are decent enough
so that's a little bit of advice if you
want to get on the path to become a
chief information security officer how
do you get started make sure you know
the basics of Information Technology
whether it be networking cryptography
databases software during artificial
intelligence
um and and then take a course such as
the foundations of information security
course that we have here at Stanford
that's one great way to get started
um there's a bunch of resources here to
learn the basics of Information
Technology and computer science uh
Stanford uh the center for professional
development has computer science 101
which is a great course there's a whole
bunch of other great online courses as
well out there
um I after after you understand the
basics I would then encourage you to
take a course such as foundations of
information security uh foundations of
information security course that we have
here at standard at Stanford starts with
me interviewing uh Vint surf who uh is
regarded as the father of the internet
he co-architected tcpip together with
bobcon back in the 70s and the entire
internet runs on it now I interview him
not only about the history of the
internet but the history of security of
the internet one of the things that we'd
like to do here without courses at
Stanford is help people not just develop
skills and develop some knowledge to
help them enter the field but we'd love
to help develop the next generation of
leaders that can help take the field
forward and this historical context as
to uh where where the fields start
started where we are now and where we
need to take things forward is just
super important context and so uh so so
beyond understanding the foundations of
I.T and computer science understanding
the foundations of information security
would be a good next step and then
beyond that for folks that want to
become security Architects or that want
to become Chief information security
officers and I was only able to
politically touch upon three of these
roles there's some additional courses
that you can take
um summary there's a lot of opportunity
to get involved in cyber security
there's many roles available not of that
not all of them are deeply technical
um uh so please please consider joining
the field I'd be happy to take a few
questions
thank you so much Neil I always learned
so much from you so thank you so much
for sharing all of that
um one question that keeps coming up and
I know you touched on that a little bit
is for people who don't have the
technical background like how to get
started and I know you mentioned some
courses they could take a look at uh but
like what is like what do you advise
them like how to get started besides
like getting some kind of background
information about a field like in terms
of like how to find a job virtual look
um who to get in contact with what would
be your advice great so let's start with
um
how to how to get involved I mean I'd
start with just you know going on Google
News or other sources uh searching for
cyber security get a sense of what's
going on in the world right that that's
the that's the first place to start
um you know I'd encourage uh you know
you to you know read a book or two
um I think if you don't have the
technical background it is important to
take a a basic computer science course
or a basic foundations of Information
Technology course because you know if
you don't understand the basics of uh
networking and databases then it's going
to be hard to uh for instance be able to
go through Network traffic to identify
well where is the attack coming from and
what uh you know what's what's going on
there
um so I would I would encourage uh you
know to build some some basic technical
uh depth and then Petra you had said you
had also asked um you know what's up
what's a good place to get started well
I would I would encourage people to you
know go on LinkedIn uh look at look at
so I think that in order to get a job in
a field it is important to develop the
knowledge it is important to get a
certification so for instance the
professional certifications that we have
here at Stanford are are good
certifications to get like the the
foundations of information or the
advanced cyber security certification
are great to get uh but as we know in
the world it's not just about what you
know it is to an extent also uh you know
uh you know unfortunate or not about who
you know so I would encourage you to get
on LinkedIn I would encourage you to
connect with people in your in your
Professional Circle and figure out who
um you know might be working in a
security team somewhere right
um and ask them about what kind of roles
are available uh ask for you know just
an informational session you know you
don't have you know the way to get a job
is not just you know uh get a
certification and then start applying uh
and try to get interviews that's a very
hard process right there's so many
resumes that come in for every job that
I would encourage people to reach out to
people that they know interview them uh
just exploratory interviews learn about
what's going on in the world what kind
of problems are they are they solving uh
what kind of skills do they need for
their company
um and once you once you once you learn
their particular needs once you have
some certification then that's a good
then the next step is to try to get kind
of the formal job interview but there's
so much that you can learn by just
talking to people meeting people whether
it be online or in person
you don't need PhD degree in order to
get a job that's that's kind of what I
keep hearing from you that is correct
you don't need a PhD to get a job in
cyber security most people don't have
phds you know I think if you have some
bachelor's degree and by the way it
doesn't have to be in computer science
it could be electrical engineering it
could be mechanical engineering I think
having a bachelor degree in some
technical field is is a great start and
even if you don't have a bachelor's
degree in a technical field there are
csos that grew up as lawyers right so
having some some educational background
is good
um and you know such folks even if you
don't come from a technical field you
can learn the the basics of the
technical field and then go from there
great thank you so much Neil avir
unfortunately at the time uh we did get
a lot of questions so just for people
who are still with us we took notes uh
we you know kind of wrote down all of
them and we will have a follow-up
discussion with Neil and we will try to
find a way how to basically share the
knowledge further we apologize if we
couldn't get to your question like right
during this call but it was definitely
valuable to hear what you're curious
about so we know but to ask next thank
you so much Neil this was a wonderful
session uh hopefully very practical for
folks but I definitely learned a lot
about uh what is happening in the
industry what people need to know what
types of jobs there are so thank you so
much
um have a nice day everybody or like
evening morning wherever you are I
appreciate you could join us
thanks everyone for attending hope you
learned a thing you didn't know before
and look forward to being in touch